fleischbeschau im community video mit
haudegen die beiden jungs sind ja
übersät mit denen haut gemälden und da
gibt es natürlich die ein oder andere
frage und sie erzählen wie sie dran
gekommen sind und welche lustigen
tattoos sie haben das und noch viel mehr
jetzt im community video methodik die
checkliste rt 277 meine frage an habt
ihr probleme wenn ihr musikalisch mit
dem bösen onkels verglichen werden wir
haben damit kein problem also bei uns
ist so wir haben wir kennen die musik ja
also von den böhsen onkelz und wir
finden nicht das wird dann gerade
gleicher ist natürlich dass wir deutsch
singen dass wir eine raue stimme dabei
haben aber generell finden wir
eigentlich ist nicht schlimm finde ich
nicht nicht toll wenn es nicht schlimm
wie homer also wir für uns und
einzigartig wir können natürlich
nachvollziehen wenn menschen auf uns
zukommen und sagen dass ich damit
vergleichen möchten ist natürlich klar
wie es wenn gerade schon sagt es wird
deutsch gesungen ist eine raue stimme
und es ist rockig aber jeder der sich
mit unserer musik etwas näher befasst
der wird schnell merken dass bei uns
viel um liebe hoffnung und den glauben
und was besseres geht und das
unterscheidet uns ganz klar von den
onkelz die frage von richard kevin
russell
ihr habt ja viele tattoos was ist euer
wertvollste und welches bereut ihr
es gibt kein einziges sprechers mal für
dich mit es gibt kein einziges tattoo
was wir wollen das schon mal ganz vorne
weg auf jedes tattoo ist man stolz wenn
man auf jedes tattoo hat mit jedem tor
etwas verbindet ob positiv oder negativ
selbst mal dahingestellt aber bereuen
tue wir gar nichts und das schönste was
ich trage sind meine beiden kinder auf
der herz seite meine beiden kinder bei
mir sind eigentlich lustige tattoo wenn
ihr euch die dvd holt zum neuen album
angeht dann werdet ihr direkt sehen in
den ersten paar minuten von der dvd mein
lieblings natur ist und dazu hat mich
immer an meinen verstorbenen onkel
erinnert weil er an derselben stelle
eigentlich dasselbe tattoo hat und 2
sind eine lachende mit lachendem aus und
zwar genau auf der brustwarze einfach
nur zwei punkte oben drüber die ohren
die barthaare schild tuben und bereuen
tue ich natürlich keine schuld
muten möchte wissen haudegen wie kommt
man auf so einen namen
ganz einfach eigentlich wenn man schon
immer haudegen und begreift hat uns dort
englisch
unsere großväter gemacht denn wenn wir
irgendwo mist gebaut haben und nach
hause gekommen sind und die ganzen
kohlen flecken eine klamotten hatte und
die ja nicht wissen wollten was wieder
englisch gemacht haben mal gesagt wie
ihr seid mein papa oder die alten haben
und als wir als wir dann als wir
angefangen zu singen haben dann halt
einfach überlegt was sind wir eigentlich
für typen menschen sind irgendwie wir
sind schon irgendwie anders wie die
anderen bekommen so kannte ich um die
ecke sagen immer sofort was wir denken
und so weiter und wir sind haudegen und
haudegen ist ja nicht nur die
bezeichnung für unsere band dafür für
für die musik die wir machen seiner
bezeichnung für eine art von mensch ist
wie gesagt ein aufrichtiger mensch der
ehrlich ist der immer sachwalter denkt
und für seine leute ein steht haye hagen
heiß wenn ich hoffe mir beiden kennt
mich noch meine frage lautet was war von
euch beiden jeweils das allererste tue
und was für die bedeutung länder über
eine antwort würde ich mich sehr freuen
und ja macht weiterhin die beste mutter
der welt ich freuen
wow mein herz mein blut für die familie
bund fürs leben
superklasse wir kennen ihn wie kenn dich
nicht lacken für dich eher sind derzeit
wo unser bürger draußen mcdonald mariga
checkt somit kamera und sogar richtig
gewesen die kappen letztens erst wieder
getroffen jamboree ja also erst bei mir
waren erst natürlich 14 wartet hier so
sieht so aus das sollte eigentlich mein
chinesische zeichen werden dann steht
für für wild also für wilde in mir hat
man damals schon findet will denn mir
war eigentliche zeit wo ich mich
behaupten musste und ja zeigen musste
das in mir auch ein kerl steckt und
deswegen habe ich mir als belohnung
sozusagen diese tour macht eine
belohnung für fachartikel und nein ich
hab dich angestellt ich hab halt einfach
mein mann ist an ok da gab es leute die
mich damals als kleiner junge
unterdrücken wollten und so weiter und
ich hab mich dagegen auf ihr bäumt und
manni standen und haben mit ihr könnt
natürlich machen und das war die
belohnung für mich selber halten tut mir
zu machen und dann war diese der
chinesische zeichen was wild bedeutet ja
so mein lieber tolle frage und sie haben
können so ändern schöne grüße von mir
mein erstes auto war ein schriftzug den
ich selber entworfen habe es wenn
candela markus hof zeigen
der sieht auch heute noch immer so schön
scheiße aus wie damals
und da steht drauf monday to make sense
das war in einer zeit gestochen wo es
wirklich verrückte zeit das war eine
verrückte zeit und es war alles sehr
sehr schwierig und ich hab mir sozusagen
damals zu einer birne kratz 100 mich
gefragt wann macht eigentlich alle zehn
was du hier machst und habe mir dieses
motto auf den arm tätowieren lassen dass
ich sage eines tages wird alles einen
sinn ergeben
in der küche im plattenbau
weil denzel wissen willst doch zwei
autofelgen hat gesessen
am küchentisch das war so eine
anderthalb quadratmeter küche einer
platte hält und ein kumpel von mir hat
im prinzip bestochen und ich war glaube
ich sechzehn oder siebzehn also war
verrückte zeit und ich wusste nicht
wohin und ich lasse es auch so wie es
ist weil es mich immer daran erinnert
dass so eine verrückte zeit waren als
meine kinder auf die welt kam hat
sozusagen dieser satz seine bedeutung
gefunden und da wusste ich dann der sinn
des lebens sind meine beiden kinder
weltbewegende fragen gibt es immer in
der community videos von klicks um zb
die an poker nach dem leoparden modus
dem entwickler von apple bricht aus jan
müller-michaelis ob er verrät wie man
rein kommt oder nicht dass er vater im
community video mit ihm also wenn er
unbedingt in den leopard leoparden modus
kommen wollt was immer das auch ist ich
habe überhaupt keine ahnung vielleicht
schreibt dass man darunter ich dann
würde ich mich immer bemüht in diesem
komischen modus zu kommen so und mit der
fleuth im community videos wird der noch
kein modus kommen sondern der erklärt ob
er lieber vorbild oder entertainer ist
und begründet das auch also wenn er das
unbedingt erfahren wollt dann solltet
ihr das community video mit lief lang
ansehen
viel spaß bei dem oder bei dem video